even though it's bigger than we expected
we don't consider it a planet do we well
you know from a NASA perspective we
really don't care what we call what that
classification is and the reason why is
this is a body a system actually with
the five moons that are there that is
well worthy of X exploration by NASA
what what do we gain from this other
than it being so cool and so exciting
and reminding us all of interstellar I
mean what do we get from this as far as
scientific data that we can use in the
real world here so far away well you
know just in the matter of the last 20
years we've discovered this region
called the Kuiper belt for which Pluto
is the archetype and there might be tens
of thousands of objects like this
scattered out well beyond Pluto a whole
brand-new region of our solar system you
know we're uncovering these things only
because we look only because we explore
and what we understand now is that this
region is leftover material from our
collapsing cloud that created the
planets both terrestrial ones that we
know and gas giants so where does that
fit in where does it fit in does this
give you some idea of when like the
final entropy is going to bring us all
to death well not exactly but you know
by understanding our solar system which
we absolutely have to do we then
understand how we survive as human
species you know we're constantly
bombarded by a variety of objects and
perhaps at one time well in the past we
believe the solar system had a major
shake-up bringing many of these Kuiper
belt objects inward perhaps all the way
into the inner part of our solar system
and with that bringing a lots of water
and other parts of things that we now
take for granted and
and may have produce life who knows with
this is one of the reasons why science
is so important to continue on this
track so that we can figure out where we
come from and where we're going Jim you
may not see this but where we have a
graphic of the satellite and it says
things like Pepsi or Alice or Ralph what
are these things that we're looking at
on this vehicle well those are names of
experiments we have seven on board New
Horizons you know Ralph makes those
color images Alice makes all kinds of
complicated scientific spectra that
allows us to tell us the composition
Laurie is that really high-resolution
black and white or panoramic image earth
at we've used so often and that everyone
is seeing the data from so these are
fabulous sets of instruments that are
doing wonderful job of really
investigating this environment I wonder
just because this movie has piqued our
interests are we ever going to be able
to get to Pluto faster I mean ten years
is pretty fast for three billion miles
but I mean can we get there in a shorter
amount of time we you know the fact that
we have created a spacecraft and we put
it on our trajectory and we've done
these things is due to the fact that
we're developing the technologies to
make these happen there are enabling
technologies that were doing now in
various other parts of our program that
we want to leverage to be able to go out
to the outer part of our solar system on
a more regular basis one of these
systems is the Space Launch System this
is this huge rocket being developed by
human exploration it's fact even more
powerful than the Saturn vibes and it
will literally open up the outer part of
our solar system to us because we'll be
able to get out there so much more
faster